Caesar's cipher is also
called shift cipher,
because each letter is map to another
letter by fixed amount of shift.
So if we represent letters as numbers,
meaning A is 1, B is 2 and Z is 26.
Then this encryption scheme or
cipher can be represented as the letter,
meaning the integer plus n,
the fixed amount marked 26.
Here the shift amount n is a secret,
or the key.
And obviously,
there are only 26 possible keys.
Therefore, it is easy to
break Caesar's cipher
because you only need to
try 26 possible keys.
A generalization of
this scheme is to allow
arbitrary mapping of
one letter to another.
That is, we no longer require that
a letter is map to another letter
by always the fix amount of shift.
Now of course,
we need to avoid that two letters
are being mapped to the same letter.
Demapping, meaning how each
letter is map to another,
it is now the secret key.
Can you tell,
how many possible keys are out there?
Meaning, how many possible ways
to map one letter to another.
The answer is 26 factorial,
because there are 26 factorial number
of ways to map one letter to another.
Please note that n factorial is
much larger than 2 to the n.
For example, 26 factorial is
approximately 2 to the 88th,
which is much larger than 2 to 26th.
In other words,
this is very huge number.
If the attacker attempts
to use brute force, or
just blindly search all the possible
keys, it's going to take him long time,
because there are 2 to the 88th
number of possible keys.
So, what should the attacker do instead?
Instead of trying all of the possible
keys, an attacker can analyze
the statistical frequencies of
letters to break the schemes.
For example, in English,
the most frequently used letter is E.
And if in a cipher text,
the letter X is the most frequent,
then there's a high probability
that E is mapped to X.